turning to the coronavirus millions of
americans are now eligible for coveted
booster shots after the centers for
disease control and prevention widened
the pool of eligibility on friday anyone
18 or older can now get a third shot six
months after their last dose of a pfizer
or modern vaccine or two months past the
single dose johnson and johnson vaccine
it comes as the average number of covid
cases in the nation is up 24
since november 4th elise preston is here
with the story elise good morning good
morning across the country governors and
health officials are bracing as they try
to avert a winter surge of coronavirus
cases the cold weather and upcoming
holidays when people gather indoors
could fuel high case loads like ones we
are already seeing in some states
the unvaccinated have swelled minnesota
icu beds to capacity more than 3
thousand covett patients are
hospitalized in michigan a number not
seen since the spring they are among
four upper midwest states with the
highest rates of new covid cases
the message has to be loud and clear you
can't run out the game clock on this one
this virus will find you as travelers
start heading home for thanksgiving
health officials hope booster shots will
help those already vaccinated avoid
getting sick if you're one of the
approximately 100 million
people in this country already eligible
for a booster our recommendation is that
you get the extra protection afforded by
a booster as soon as possible three out
of every 10 americans remain
unvaccinated philadelphia yesterday
became the latest big city to mandate
vaccinations for its 26 000 employees
joining a dozen others including los
angeles and chicago other cities are
tempering mandates by allowing regular
testing for unvaccinated workers instead
and some places are going to court
watching the backlash is professor
alison hoffman who writes about health
care law and policy at the university of
pennsylvania and going back 116 years to
1905 a case called jacobson versus
massachusetts the court said
that
that in cases where
there is a public health need that
states and localities can can put public
health measures into place and so things
like vaccination mandates and other
public health measures have a long
history
meanwhile two new studies reveal the
risk covid presents to pregnant women
one shows the risk of death is more than
three times higher in covet positive
pregnant women another study found the
risk of stillbirths increased by 90
percent only about 35 percent of
pregnant women are vaccinated the cdc
recommends the vaccine for pregnant
women jeff elise thank you very much at